[Musique]
d'accord
bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 20
septembre vous regardez le sait depuis
que le journal excusez-nous pau ce petit
problème technique on commence tout de
suite avec les titres
polémiques un camp de migrants
pourraient être installés à l'ancienne
et cela ne fait pas l'unanimité hier une
manifestation organisée par le front
national a eu lieu à versailles sur ce
sujet nous y reviendrons prend et la loi
se durcit pour les fraudeurs dans les
transports une campagne de communication
est lancée pour leur rappeler les
nouvelles sanctions auxquelles ils ne
pourront échapper et enfin nous vous
présenterons les nouveaux pensionnaires
du parc du château de plaisir une
dizaine de vins pour entretenir les
jardins cela sahel l'écopâturage
et de l'actualité de ce mardi le
ministre de la justice jean jacques
urvoas a présenté ce matin son plan
prisons dont l'un des objectifs est de
parvenir à 80% de détenus en cellule
individuelle un plan qui va permettre
également d'améliorer les conditions de
détention à la prison de bois d'arcy
elle était selon patrick moko secrétaire
local ufap bois d'arcy dans une
situation assez déplorable et c'est
déplorable écouter le nous l'avons eue
par téléphone
la situation est critique à vos leur
fille en terme de population
mais ça ça va toujours été il n'y a
jamais eu le changement jamais rien n'a
été fait nous avons actuellement un peu
plus de 900 détenus
place donc cela provoque
rappel et sur des airs sur des rampes et
donc un jardres delà de la fatigue
morale et physique et tout cela bien
provoc de l'attention des arts est
forcément mais
voilà
je vous disais en titre les inquiétudes
et les interrogations grandissent autour
d'un centre d'accueil pour migrants qui
doit être installé bientôt dans les
yvelines des premières informations
parler d'un cas les bisses situé sur la
commune de l'ancien des informations
démenties par la préfecture après un
rendez vous avec le maire de la ville
les précisions de michael elle met
d'euros et nicolas kirillovitch
un camp de migrants va-t-il être
installés ici à louveciennes la rumeur
enfle de plus plusieurs jours la
préfecture des yvelines a ciblé
plusieurs sites sur le département dont
la plaine de villevayre pour accueillir
une centaine de migrants le lieu en
question est un ancien pôle industriel
de 24 hectares actuellement en friche
situé à proximité de cette discothèque
et du triangle de rocquencourt une
nouvelle est une façon de faire qui
agace le maire de la commune c'est
toujours si vous voulez embêtant enfin
je veux dire agaçant pour pas dire
fortement irritants
d'apprendre les choses par par là par
les médias et que les maires qui sont
quand même le premier niveau de
démocratie démocratie locale n'ait pas
été informé j'ai été irrité par le fait
qu'on puisse nous imposer que l'état
puisse nous imposer
des choses que nous n'avons sur lesquels
nous n'avons pas été concertés une
nouvelle qui préoccupe également le
front national la section départementale
du parti de marine le pen a organisé
hier un rassemblement devant la mairie
de versailles
nous ce qu'on dénonce c'est de manière
générale l'immigration illégale
et maintenant quelle sûr que cette
immigration illégale ce s'installe dans
les yvelines c'est déplorable
effectivement pour les yvelines et pour
les habitants dvd en tant que secrétaire
départementale des yvelines c'est de mon
devoir de le dénoncer selon la
préfecture des yvelines aucune date ni
aucun lieu précis n'ont été retenu à ce
jour
la lutte contre la fraude nouvel enjeu
de taille pour la région ile de france
aujourd'hui la sncf la ratp et le stif
représenté par valérie pécresse on
conjointement une conférence de presse
pour annoncer le lancement d'une grande
campagne de communication intitulée
fraudeurs pour vous les règles ont
changé
elle vise à rappeler aux usagers le
durcissement des sanctions à l'encontre
des fraudeurs depuis la promulgation en
mars de la loi savary le roof des
amendes plus élevées et plus d'outils
pour les agents que vous allez le voir
la chasse aux fraudeurs est lancée avec
la promulgation de la loi dite leroux
savary du 22 mars 2016 est inspirée des
propositions de valérie pécresse le
cadre se durcit pour les fraudeurs en
2015 la ratp a comptabilisé 1 25 million
d'infractions 510 milles et pour
transilien moi je trop déroutant je ne
savais pas attraper mais bon c'est pas
trop risqué de fraude et parce qu'il n'y
a pas tant que ça de contrôleurs dans
les bus donc au final n'en ce pas risqué
frauder pas s'y risquer les
transporteurs veulent prouver le
contraire la loi le roux savard et punit
déjà la déclaration de fausses identités
de deux mois d'emprisonnement et de 3750
euros damende
le délit dit d'habitude lui ait relevé
plus de cinq infractions sur une année
et le fraudeurs s'exposent à six mois
d'emprisonnement et 7500 euros damende
d'autres dispositions entreront en
vigueur prochainement aujourd'hui les
personnels de la ratp la sncf seront
tous assermentés pour contrôler et on
pourra aussi avoir des patrouilles en
civil de sécurité sur le réseau ratp sur
le réseau sncf la loi a changé et ça va
devenir beaucoup plus difficile de
frauder et surtout ça va être beaucoup
plus pénalisant parce que si vous aller
quelque part et qu'on vous retient
plusieurs heures pour que vous prouviez
votre identité eh bien ce sera difficile
des mesures censées faciliter le travail
des agents sur le terrain le fait de
communiquer sur ce nouveau délit
de faire savoir que ce serait au
contrôle peut entraîner une peine de
prison une peine d'amendé importantes a
évidemment un effet dissuasif dans la
toujours besoin d'un renfort mais c'est
vrai que vous avez beaucoup de voyageurs
qui ne présentent pas leur classe
d'identité qui ne veulent pas la
présenter et c'est vrai que c'est assez
accidentogène chaque année la ratp
consacre 1250 agents et 90 millions
d'euros à la lutte contre la fraude pour
le stif la ratp et la région ile de
france l'enjeu est avant tout financier
nous avons demandé à la ratp de faire 20
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
supplémentaire grâce à la lutte contre
la fraude et à la sncf de faire 10
millions c'est des objectifs très
ambitieux en 2015 la cour des comptes a
évalué à 366 millions d'euros le coût de
la fraude en ile-de-france
et en politique et les élus de saint
quentin faisait hier leur rentrée 38
points étaient à l'ordre du jour
économie à budget ou encore
environnement ou fait le point sur la
séance s'est dit hier soir avec vous ils
frais des riches y bonsoir alors on
commence avec des sujets qui ont fait
débat entre majorité et opposition
notamment un projet d'aménagement celui
de la gare des cannes à la verrière
bonsoir floral un projet qui n'était
même pas à 100 c'est être à l'ordre du
jour mais nelly duthu la mère de la
verrière a pris la parole pendant le
conseil d'agglomération accompagné des
élus de sa majorité municipale qui était
présent dans le public elle a évoqué un
blocage de la part de l'agglomération à
l'annoncé elle son intention de confier
la maîtrise d'ouvragé à l'état cette zac
de la gare bécane en détail c'est à
terme 1800 logements construits à la
création d'un pôle d'activité de 80
mille mètres carrés et un pôle
multimodal également tout ça pour une
ville de 6000 habitants où vous l'avez
compris c'est un projet d'envergure
michel auger le président de saint
quentin en yvelines elle s'est donc
défendu il dénonce lui le choix fait par
la ville de confier ce projet à l'état
il veut simplement que l'on prenne plus
de temps sur un dossier et ce récit
structurants en consultant par exemple
les villes voisines comme celles d'el en
cours qui serait fortement et forcément
impactées alors votre si j'ai attendu le
vote de certaines subventions pour des
associations devraient composer
principalement problème celui de
l'association pour le rayonnement de
port royal des champs les élus ont voté
une baisse de la subvention de près 750
euros une décision qui a dénoncé la
gauche et surtout à bertrand lyon le
maire ps de magny les hameaux la
majorité s'est finalement engagé à
revoir ce montant et puis les élus
devaient se prononcer sur la première
subvention de l'association des
locataires de trappes et d'île de france
alors qu'elle avait décidé a pris cette
décision en commission finalement les
élus la majorité l'opposition ont voté
après plusieurs prises de parole et ils
ont voté contre conclusion ce n'est pas
de leur ressort de soutenir ce type de
structure des points l'ordre seront
quand même a fait l'unanimité rassurer
nous il y avait de nombreux de nombreux
points et bien évidemment beaucoup ont
fait l'unanimité les élus ont par
exemple décidé de soutenir les
librairies indépendantes en les
exonérant totalement de cotisation
foncière des entreprises pareil pour les
cinémas qui réalisent moins de 450 mille
entrées par an la droite et gauche ont
également soutenu l'association club
climat énergie de 50 ans à hauteur de
15000 euros ou encore différentes
associations culturelles du territoire
voilà pour quelques-uns des nombreux
points qui ont été abordés hier pour
cette conférence réunion de rentrée pour
les élus de l'agglo et bien merci à
wilfrid pour toutes ces précisions je
vous propose maintenant de prendre un
peu d'air et d'aller vers plaisir depuis
ce lundi le château accueille deux
nouveaux pensionnaires une dizaine de
brebis bélier est cher mais aussi des
moutons sont dans le parc du château
pour deux mois le but tondre la pelouse
de manière naturelle sans recourir aux
produits phytosanitaires mélanie poker
vous parle de ces nouveaux jardiniers
la sortie était plutôt hésitante mais
très vite les ovins ont pris leurs
marques leur présence n'est pas anodine
ils vont entretenir le parc du château
de plaisir faire de l'éco pâturages
c'est nettoyer
les espaces verts eux
à l'aide des animaux les animaux pâture
les cités et nettoie tout en préservant
bien sûr c'est ce qui est le plus
essentiel en préservant la biodiversité
des sites et
favorisera
le développement de l'écosystème en fait
présent à la demande de la mairie les
ovins seront dans le parc durant un an
pas d'économies pour la commune
l'entretien des jardins représentent
2800 euros chaque année c'est dans
l'esprit du zéro phyto que la ville
applique déjà depuis trois ans puisque
au niveau de l'ensemble des espaces de
la ville où il ya donc de l'herbe nous
utilisons donc l'eau chaude on a donc
sélectionné deux parcelles sur le parc
du château à une partout par celle
d'anne hectares sis une parcelle d'un
hectare 2 et donc le berger va vous nous
déplacer ce que le mouton sur ses
différentes parcelles dans deux mois ils
seront mis à l'abri pour l'hiver avant
de repartir entretenir les autres zones
du parc est allé à la rencontre des
plaisirs wa une solution acquis pour
vous donner des idées si vous avez
également un jardin on finit ce journal
avec du sport la 7e édition des
olympiades de versailles s'est tenue ce
samedi au stade de mont boron le concept
une centaine de valider de personnes en
situation de handicap participent
ensemble à des ateliers pendant la
journée au programme de l'équitation du
football de la natation ou encore de la
pétanque je vous propose de regarder ce
reportage signé michael el mundo et
camille lambert
des rires des performances sportives la
7e édition des olympiades de versailles
était programmée dans la ville ce
week-end au stade mob auront le concept
les valides et les non valides se
retrouvent pour partager un moment de
sport quand on est face à une personne
en situation de handicap on va aller
vers elle en disant je vais faire une
berge
donc on va aller vers cette personne on
va comprendre quel est son type de
handicap on va s'adapter elle pour
pouvoir l'aider et l'accompagner et pour
moi c'est les bases du vivre ensemble
le vivre ensemble c'est aller vers
l'autre comprendre l'autre écouter quels
sont ses besoins et s'adapter à l'eau
pour faire passer un moment là pendant
cette journée les participants ont pu
notamment s'essayer à l'équitation
l'activité était organisée par le club
hippique de versailles partenaire de
l'épreuve depuis la première édition
c'est je crois une activité qui plaît
énormément sur ces journées des
olympiades ou les
les personnes peuvent venir découvrir et
se mettre à cheval et voilà découvrir
les sensations que procure la mise à
cheval
sereinement dans une ambiance festive
du beaucoup de bien j'en fais depuis un
bout de temps déjà
l'événement attiré près de 1000
participants cette année rendez vous en
juin 2017 pour une nouvelle édition des
olympiades de versailles
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous donne rendez vous demain pour un
nouveau numéro du journal et vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur tv5
[Musique]